.
TH WAS PATHETIC.
THANYOU BOTH.
TOGHT, WE ARE NOT EVETHROH
E YEAR.
ONOF -- YEAR ONE A
E BIDEN'S PRESENCY.
THGS HAVE GO  MIKE ON SO
POORLY THAT EVEN S BIEST
FENDERS INHE MEDIA MOB -
BIDEN SHOULD ROO NOTUN AGAIN
AND SHOULDAY HE WON'T.
COLUMNISBACKEGGING HIM NOT
TO SEEK A SECD TERM, CALLI
HI "ALARMINGLY IOHERT."
IF YOU ARE A DEMRAT AND
SOONE AT "THNEW YORK TIMES
CAS YOU ALARMINGLYNCOHENT,
AND MAY BE TIME TO PACKT IN.
ANMEANILE THE MEDIARM OF
DEN' 202 ARM, FAKE NEWNN,
TH PUBLISH TS.
11 DOCRA THAT COULD REPLACE
JOE BIDEN IN 2024.
EY DON'T EVEN WANT HIMO RUNAGAIE
CAPABLE OFUNNI FOR SECON
TERM.
IT LISTS 1RANDOM DEMOCRATS TO
TA THE LD ON THE TICKET.
NOBLY . FOUL MISSING FROM
THE LT IMEONE WHO WLD NO
DOUBT LOVE ATHER OPPORTUNI TO BE
LLED MAD PRESIDENT.
WIOUT A DOU,HE ONE AND
ONLY HILLA CLINTON IS READY
AND WILLINGO ANSWER THATALL.
D ACCORDING TMY NEXT GUEST,
A MEDIU THI JOEONCHA, SHE
MIGHBE THEIR BESTOPE.
I DOT TNK THAT IS THEIR BESTHOP.
E CONCHA ALONGITH X NEWS
CORIBUTOR AS WE MIRANDA
DEVINE.
E, WHEN YOU LOOK AT TIST,
KAML, PETE BUTTIGIE
Y KLOBUCHAR.
NOT EXACTLY A DEE BENCH OF
MOCRATS THAT Y C LOOK AT
AT THIS MOMENT AT IEE AND I
SAY  WOULD BE WORRIED ABOUT
THATNE.
SUR.
TWO POLHOW THE STORY.22%, BASAE
VOTERS, S THEY WT JOE BIDEN
TOUN I 2024.
COUL YOU IMAGI THAT NUMBER
WITH DALD TRUMP?
HE WAS ALWAYS UPROUND 90% OF
LOYALTY WIIN H PARTY.
AND WN YOU TALK DEMOCRATS, AI HR
ALL,NLY A SMIDG OVER
ONE-IRD WANT JOE BIDEN E
PRIDEN AND A SECOND RM.
HE WILL BE 86 A TT POINT.SO I W.
I'M NOT ARGUING THAT SHE I A
GREAT CANDIDATE O LIKLE OR
THENTIC OR HASNY GUNDN
PRINCIPLE,'M SING THE
DEMOATICARTY IS WHEN YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUPOTENTIAL
PRESENTIAL CANDIDAS IT'S
LIKE A CONFEREE I THE NFL.
IF THAT CONFEREE ISADE UP
ENTIRE OF AND I HATE TO SAY
THIS, THE NEW YK JE AND
ANTS, BECSE HILLARY SEE
THESE OONENTS AND SAYWELL,
WAIT A MINE, WT IS GOING TO
STOP ME FROM GETTING THE
NOMINAON?
MLA?
BP TO DGE?WHAT IS HE GOING TOUN?
NOT AVAILABLE FOR CMENT.
ELIZABETH WAEN?
HO DID SHE DO IN 2020
RNIE?
HE WOU BE IN THE0s A THEEND OF .
ALSO PL MURPHY, ANDHE
GOVEOR OF MY STAYERE IN
NEW JERSEY WHO BARELY WON
REECTI.
ETCHEN WHITMER STACEY ABRAMS
O I HLEDROAIMING H
ELTION IS STON.
FUNNY HOW THAT WOS.
GIVING ALL THESE VERSIONS  THE
NEW RK JETS AND GNTS, WHY
NOT HLARYT THEEMOCRATIC
NOMIE WHEN YOU CONDER THE
COMPETION?
>>RANDA >YES, HILLARY SOSHE CANN
SPECCULARLY.
AT W A HILARIOUS COLN, JOE
JOE,ND IT CERTAINLYAKES
THIN INTERESTED TNK THAT
HILLAR MIGHT COME BA.
D YOU'RE RIG.TH REST OF THE DEMD
SEEM TO  PRETTY LACUSTE
ANI THINK THAT'SECAUSE THEY
AR NOT LISTENINGO THE PEOPLE.
THE ONLY RSON THE JOE BID
WOLASTIME WAS BECAU HE W
PRESENTED AS MODATE, A
UNIFIER
OPLE WERE CRYING OUFOR ME
SORT OFNIFYING PRESIDT
WITHOUEALLYEALIZING THAT AS
A MIRAGE.
SO MAY THE DOCRATS
REDIATED THEIR PROESSIVE,
THEIR RADICALTANCES.
IN THE PR.
ITAS INCREDIBLE.
ALL TH IDE LIKE STAING THE
PREMCOURT AND ALISHING THE
ELECTORA COLGE AND SOMEONE
THE ARE A MAINSTREAMED BY
THE CANDIDATES.
THE DECRATIC PARTY HAS BEEN
PULLED SO RD TO THE LEFT TT
IS HAS BECOMUNELTABLE.
Sean: DONALD TRUMPUST
VE TO SITACK ANDET TM
CONTIN TO FAIL AND THEN MAKE
AN ANNOUNCENT THAT IS GNG TO
REINATE A THE OTHER POLIES
THATE HAD WHE HE WAS
PRESIDENT.
IOULDN'T DO A SINGLE INTERVIEW
IF I WAS HIM.
HE DOESN'T EN HAVE TO DO
DEBATE.
AND JUST SHOW UP A